I don't. I did for cation station seven we face. Bandler.
And interviewed by Carolyn Craig
and the tape will begin in a few seconds time in divide interview cation recorded in Sydney on Thursday the seventeenth
of July nine hundred ninety seven. Take coming up in a few seconds.
Face at the end of the last session we were in Vienna. So maybe you could continue the story from there.
It was nice going back to Vienna for work where we had stayed for about a fortnight or more.
It seemed for too long at first strangely primitive.
But we allowed for that because there was very little in the country on the whole the war was just over.
Can you imagine the city of Vienna where that coffee. And the coffee we were drinking had been sent over from. What.
And it was well it just wasn't coffee. So it was at work.
It was extremely primitive There was just a stream running through the came.
The Austrian young people had been erected and we were living in that.
But we had to do our laundry and out by here in the street.
And the food was you know it was pretty tough because they just couldn't get food after it was so so difficult. So.
After a bit we were all doubled into some pastors and taken back to the city of Vienna.
The feeling was wish we could stay here for a bit low Vienna had been battered badly. Particularly the Opera House.
I think the railway stations were bettered also heavily. But by then the trains were running in a sort of why. Anyhow.
We were told that we could stay the night in an hour in the next day I think it was and the day after that we.
They sent by train to.
Well I just had one move walk through the Vinnies markets and that was where I'd have my breakfast each morning.
Glass of milk. Had to drink something to keep a strength of a little off. And I roll and sausage.
With the very last and so after they were in the markets they were also selling.
So we were all over I walked through the streets of Iran and I recall go into one coffee shop that had not been there.
And I always remember the man who owned it. He was short and fat. And he smoked his cigar in a part.
But it was so simple you know. One could sit there is long granted and no one would. I would not dream of them.
And coffee for support where he got it from goodness knows but it was there. Anyhow.
And the day after I had walked the streets of Vienna. Where I bought a skirt of wool ski. His feet Affleck's. And.
It went very well with the gold jumpers I bought in Italy and everything was so cheap so rate.
And productive I'm sure the makers and the NE have.
The next day we were off to Berlin and that was great excitement because you must remember that.
This was the beginning of August that the first of August
and we had been travelling in living out of the suitcase since the beginning of June.
So there was great excitement and we went up to that if we were taken up to the very spot on her off
and put it in the trains. Well I was reminded of the days of the war when. We who worked in the land me.
Not recognised not considered service or always made to travel even where it was called the dog boxes
and they were just too long wooden seats for the wreck over the top and we faced the other person look.
In the other person's face as we traveled around New South Wales. Well he with his dog boxes.
So we set off and I expected the train to get us over to have to have a damn the trip again
and I can't remember how long. It took place last time which was only about four or five years ago.
But it was certainly nothing like the trip that first day of August in ninety fifty one
and we have banned all the land logged in to the train.
And train moved so slowly I expected it to wheeze off you know thinking of Austrian German efficiency.
Well it was sadly lacking our completely.
And it crawled it virtually crawled across the middle of the summer and we was thirsty.
And it was hard to get food and it was hard to get water just water to drink.
So finally we travelled for quite some hours and I don't think we've crossed the border it.
It never did more than say about at the very most. I reckon twenty five miles an hour if we were lucky. And.
They knew the places the driver was told that he had us aboard there was no particular station stopped it stopped
anywhere where there was water.
It seemed to me and we'd get out of the train and go and drink from our hands at the tapes.
And I have a feeling it took us from very very very early morning. Until late at night to get him to bed early.
And I think that trip normally takes a few hours.
I must check that but it never traveled fast it just crept along
and then we realized there were hundreds of other trains from all.
Other countries creeping along all going to take their human cargo into belly and.
It was an amazing thing you know the trains were coming in from Italy coming from France.
I just can't see all of this because people there were so many people displaced after the war
and there was tremendous movement between countries really they were all coming to the festival. How come the festival.
Yes Oh yes. And so what. So now you must be Cali from Cali in France and coming from different places in Italy.
Because you know when most Illini came to power he made sure the Runaways were very efficient and the stations were.
Beautiful absolutely beautiful. And these were not actually all destroyed in the war.
So let me tell you had very little trouble getting up there to Berlin.
But of course you see the guts had been bombed out in Germany and pretty well out of Austria
and so they could only move very slowly and then the trains were coming in from Moscow and Warsaw or. Budapest.
Way from. Sofia Bulgaria and. And they were all there to Berlin.
So you so what you got maybe outskirts of burly in we move on
and you got to sit now you just got to sit with we exhausted. And it was very little food.
So we were hungry and we were. But the whole time. One would think. Well.
What have we got to complain about the hundreds of thousands this train in the rubble no doubt.
Doesn't matter if we get without food for a day or a night what does that matter. Think of how the people who suffered.
And there was still to quieten exist in an element of hatred for the Germans among all the delegates I'm sure.
Because there we were staring at what we had absolutely yes.
So finally we were allowed taken into Berlin and allowed out of the train and to confront.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of cameras because the world press was there. Well not from the West but.
But the what thousands of people from the United States
and the Latin American countries there with cameras waiting for these people to come in from Australia.
I went by so only white people popping out of the train did you did.
Oh yes and I thought that you know a stranger certainly end up paying gurus and.
You know can I stop and turn the heater on I could remember the histories I was young and strong
and I never worried about my caps it didn't matter at all.
It's just grown I came through my image applied to most of the women in the delegation.
So there was no fuss and there was no television so we had nothing to worry about.
And then we were taken to another school where we. See schools were built. They were given a very high priority.
After the war.
It seemed to me anyhow in Austria and Germany and we were housed in I think the school creation some of that most
or so we were housed in the schools all the delegates.
Most of them were housed in the schools
and this was of course in East Berlin in East Berlin yes because I was just going to ask you what your response was
when you first saw the war. But the war wasn't the thing.
The war wasn't there until a few years after that quite a few actually but the next morning.
Someone came one of the German people who were looking after us came and said there is a woman here to meet you face
and she wants to take you away to have some coffee.
I had been corresponding with an anthropologist from about university you to phone. By the name of.
So and it was wonderful to meet this woman who knew Packer responded.
And she said Well come and see what the results of come see the results of. And I did I had a fair bit of German then.
And her English was quite good actually.
When she used to write to me always write in English so it was pretty good and. We moved through the streets.
And it was nothing. You could say no building. Lee rubble. And buildings.
That were wrecked and theaters for the festival. Very good or bad adequate no problems. Plenty of room.
And many of the stages in the you own to the Linden were set in the street.
What was one of the great buildings they were opening a state yes and I can recall it must be in about a third fourth.
And we were participating in a conference in a concert an open air concert
and I said look there are fastens of Germans who want to hear the concerts and it's famous we want to give them a go.
So we'll have to open concerts and that we're just platform.
Nothing else just a huge platform and I can recall if you play me singing to these Germans in German.
Still did in our car or can recall that they were crazy about it. And I can recall. Margaret focus saying to me after.
She said You should really sing there is a preacher. And I think singing. Let's bridge collection. You know Myra.
Lullaby. There are four or five. Them and I had already been singing that. Are saying if you just went.
They'd never heard anything like it much less so
but a black person singing in German to the mother I could only vote and it is just you know I think of that
and I think my God The world has shrunk since then. Anyhow took me around it went and had coffee.
And she had her little son who would be coming up sixteen can hardly believe it. So.
Face would you like to just continue. So I was in Berlin for the festival lasted for two weeks.
There were magnificent performances like to see who was the star of the Bolshoi ballet performance one like amidst this
city and for all. And a whole. Never forget you know. I didn't take a human being could. It was because. And of course.
Singers musicians. And when the good pianist came from. I don't know but they were there.
It's hard for me really to describe. How devastated. Europe was. Nothing was left. And marked. And this city.
And also put your. When there was nothing. There was left of. The hours of early. And I thought of as the place.
That manufactured the most beautiful China that had ever been manufactured. And the treasures you know treasures.
Not only. The treasures that originated in Germany the treasures from throughout the whole world but there.
And as I walked these places these roads that were one street. In the suburbs where people lived.
It's impossible for me to really just I have to think about this and I've got to find out means
and ways of describing my emotions at that time. It's have to believe there are just so many bodies below that.
So we're all working hard. And it only happened four or five years before that this is incredible.
Absolutely critical and I'm just so pleased to read the autobiography written by. The Australian journalist.
On one of Hitler's. And had some other thing. They hadn't that I know now I would have understood that situation.
Of devastation in those two cities. I would have understood it better. And. This man. You know this is very the bone.
Of the street. Doing a bit of painting. Was able to bring that great country. You know the country.
I think thinking and I have said it in fact recently. When talking about the problem.
We make little of hands that can't happen here. While you I mean who would have thought you know.
Such tragedy could be wrote this one person.
And he was entirely regarded I mean he was unveiled about he would say absolutely nobody wandering around the streets
of. And then he moved a very into. The country. It gave us. Beethoven and. For us.
And it was also responsible those German people not the Nazi party would call them the now.
But did you have been very for not only took their own people's lives. Plus fifty million of us that one man.
Poverty stricken. Didn't have a house to live. Lived off his friends. And so when people make little.
I feel she was running down my spine and.
I better not get on to that it's another thing but I look back now at that time and I think.
As much about the beginning. Perhaps I would have understood it better. And we thought of the concentration camps.
The big concentration camps but the what hundreds of concentration camps throughout our history. And Germany.
And yes in many cases was brought about by. Lifting heavy stones and walking up.
Until it dropped and pointless take the stone and take the stone. And then take it down again and take it up again.
Until one dropped it. And so it was beautiful talking with.
She was at the bottom university and that was where we were having most of enemy food was brought in. Brainerd sausage.
We didn't see any greens. Unless it was a kraut.
But I would talk to me about that terrible day and she had a brother who was actually a member of the now Tea Party
but I can always recall her saying. Well.
They would you know they can cover up by saying they belong to that Nazi party and to obey the laws rules orders
and regulations.
But she still had hundreds of thousands of Germans who didn't belong to it but they went out in the streets
and they had same people. Well office.
For a fortnight we were performing every night doing the dance of the little Everett which was created by.
And on one occasion. We performed in the biggest theater. And the Soviet Union.
Some of the Army colonels and majors just to enjoy the festival and to keep an eye on the festival
but they were this performance one place was. And of course sitting with Frank.
And sitting sitting next to him on either side were very high ranking army officers from that covered in bright golden
all at and and our show. And right. Looked at them and sitting next to him this great. Streaming.
Every time we performed the dance even though we're off to the office here and perform that. And the obvious would cry.
After the day after that particular performance.
I was involved in another play which my group had also created that had to do with the arrival of the convicts in
Australia. And they were backstage. Came the. You. Flowers.
And the flowers were being brought in from Poland for truck around especially for the festival and what they were free.
In. It was my experience.